okay this is a codage again but this
time
this Hammy
you go behind him
turn
take
oh
okay please try and get this if you've
got enough space
oh not supposed to get aggressive over
here
there we go
right so let's look slowly I'm on this
hand me
if I go oh oh I just made it
then you've got to start you're in your
own you're in your own way
so
it may be more for the seniors it may
not
you've got to know
the distance of his car if you can just
see him here you should be able to look
don't work out where should my feet what
should my feet be doing your feet need
to just do that really
just lift them up and down and don't try
and move them about too much that
usually puts you where you need to be
that puts you there and then you know
the rest
foreign